So to recap here,
the drug didn't get any better.
The cancer patients
didn't get any better.
You just got better at making mo
You just refined
your skills at price gouging.
Show is trying to fool people
into thinking that addressing
the climate crisis
from what it's actually doing
is to continue
to put money into fossil fuels.
Mr.
Diamond, you don't have to spend
$31 million a year in salary,
and you can't figure out
how to make up a $567 a month sh
This is a budget problem
you cannot solve.
That is California Congresswoman
Katie Porter,
who has made her share of viral
since she arrived on Capitol Hil
four years ago.
She's known
for asking
tough questions
and is often seen grilling
to top
executives of banks, big pharma,
even top administration official
She is now eyeing a new job,
this one in the US Senate.
Porter is running to replace
Senator Dianne Feinstein,
who is not seeking reelection in
Congresswoman Katie Porter joins
She has a new book out
called I Swear
Politics Is Messier Than My Mini
The book is really interesting
because it's so blunt.
And I want to talk
about that in a moment.
But there are so many headlines
we really should talk about as w
these days, including that
ruling from a Texas judge
that we're still
waiting to see what the appeal
whether or not it's going to hap
what it's going to look like.
You're concerned about that
and you believe ultimately
it will be reversed.
Why do you think that?
I think that ultimately it will
it will be appealed, certainly.
I think that if it isn't reverse
at the Supreme Court level,
we in Congress
will have to take some action.
And we have already done that.
Introducing a bill.
This was one of the quickest,
I think, bills
that we've ever put into place
had the most democratic cosigner
I think Republicans
are really misunderstanding this
It's not it's about freedom.
It's about the ability
to make your own choice.
And so I think that is a core va
of both the Democratic Party
and the Republican Party.
It's a core
value of Americans
to be able to make their own dec
about when and if to start a fam
And so if this gets appealed,
if it doesn't get overturned by
then I think
it's going to be on Congress to
And I think
we're going to have to do that.
Are you of the same mindset
that some of your colleagues
that if it's if it stands,
the FDA should ignore that rulin
Well, I think this is always
a challenging thing to think abo
How do we build confidence
in our government institutions?
And so we have our Supreme Court
and our court system
generally is facing
a crisis of public confidence.
The things we heard about
Supreme Court Justice
Clarence Thomas, of course,
a lot of outrage about that,
I think, understandably.
And so I think
the better solution here
is for Congress to step up.
I think people often
forget that
when the judiciary
and the administrative branch ar
the American people, it's
the legislative branch
that is supposed to step up.
We are the closest branch to the
And so I think the most
the best solution here
would be able to get this passed
through Congress quickly
when it comes to Justice Clarenc
And, of course,
what he's responding
to, the lavish trips
that he accepted
from a Republican megadonor.
Do you think Congress
will actually get anything passe
on that front, on the ethics
front for Supreme Court justices
We definitely need to get
a judicial code of ethics passed
for the Supreme Court.
I think Congress has more work t
about its own ethics, for exampl
passing a congressional panel
on stock trading.
And we didn't get that over
the finish line,
even with Democrats in charge.
And so I think one of the things
that I try to talk about in the
is about the importance
of us being willing
to hold ourselves accountable,
to look honestly
at what people think about Congr
and then try to make it better
or try to earn people's trust.
Don't throw up our hands
and say that
it's the other party's fault,
but instead dig in to what
we as Democrats need to do
to earn the trust of the America
You're in the House
Oversight Committee,
and there has been some tension
between the chairman of that com
James Comer,
and the ranking Democrat
on that committee,
Jamie Raskin, over Komar,
quietly issuing subpoenas.
Do you feel when it comes to
the Republican led investigation
into documents, bank records
when it pertains to Hunter Biden
do you feel like you
as a member of that committee,
have a good understanding
of what the committee is investi
Well, I think that the hearing
we've already seen on Hunter
Biden's laptop,
I called it a free for all hells
And it it really was.
The hearing itself lasted 6 hour
which is about
a third of the time
that the actual supposed
story was suppressed.
And so The New York Post story
so the story was allegedly suppr
about 18 hours.
And our hearing investigating
it lasted 6 hours.
So I think this is
not the right direction to be go
I do think it's important
to have the ability to do subpoe
I think there's a long tradition
of those being bipartisan,
and I would encourage Chairman C
to continue to do that.
He has done
some very good
bipartisan hearings
early in his time on crime in Co
including on the border
and on pandemic fraud.
And we're expecting to do an upc
hearing on Big Pharma.
And so I think he's shown an abi
to do bipartisan work.
He's also, unfortunately, someti
I think, gone
the other direction
and acted unilaterally
so that there is a positive path
And we just need to push Mr.
Kromer to lean into that
that style of working.
That's a really interesting comm
We have you here today.
You've written this book, obviou
you wrote in Congress here in th
Now, you were running for a Sena
to represent California.
One thing that California
has been in the headlines
for recently is what's happening
in San Francisco.
Just yesterday,
it was announced that
Wholefoods is closing its flagsh
there.
They're concerned about worker s
because of the property crimes
and what you've seen
in that city as a whole.
How do you have a Democrat
to deal with that?
If you're elected to the Senate,
how will you personally deal wit
Well,
I think the system needs to be a
that Democrats
lean into,
which is that
everyone should be safe
in their community.
That includes business owners
being able to open safely, worke
being able to go back and forth.
And so I think we need to priori
public safety.
That means we need to think abou
what are the solutions that actu
Not just messaging bills,
not things
that are sound bites,
which I think
is where
some of the Republican
legislation is going,
but what actually would create
a more safe environment.
And it's clear that we have work
in many of California cities.
I live in Orange County.
I live in Irvine.
It's the safest large city of it
Like umpteenth years in a row.
And so it's specific to our citi
It's specific to different strat
that we're using
and different challenges
that they're facing.
And I think
one of the things
the federal government can do is
a lot more resources
for housing to address
people experiencing homelessness
and I think provide some grants
and incentives
for cities to be more innovative
policing and safety.
Yeah, it's
certainly a concern
that a lot of people have.
Let's talk about the book
because I was reading this,
and I, as someone who lived in W
right now
of yours, was kind of struck by
how blunt it was, how honest it
It's not always something you se
from members of Congress,
but you kind of talk about
your experience
coming to Capitol Hill,
trying to kind of reform an inst
that everyone hates,
not not just people in the left,
not just people on the right.
It's kind of Congress
does not have a gut approval rat
How do you do that?
Well,
I think part of it is be transpa
with the American people.
I think there's often an
a sort of when you see this
in the political biographies,
a lot of them that have been wri
you see people kind of trying
to put a gloss on the job.
And I think instead we should be
with the American people.
This is why the job is hard.
This is why we sometimes fall do
To love
Congress, to love democracy
means being willing
to push it to do better.
And we can't do that
if we're not being honest
about where it's falling short.
So if we want to have a more
representative government,
then we need to design an instit
that's modern,
that will let us attract young p
women parents.
I'm the only single parent of yo
And when I was elected in 2018,
we have 10 million single parent
in the United States.
So I think we have to
if we love the institution,
we have to be honest about it
and not try to pretend
that these problems aren't there
Let's look squarely at them,
tackle them and take them on.
And what does that look like?
Because one of the things
I was struck by is
you talk about being
a single parent in Congress
and how difficult it is.
And because of that,
the job is easier for people
who are wealthy, people who are
You say that
someone kind of implied in there
that a solution to your problem
when you were struggling with sc
was to get married.
Yeah, not exactly like it would
People have said to me,
you can't do this job without a
And I'm like, why I'm here.
I'm doing this job.
Like, I'm
really trying to do
a really good job for California
And so I think we need
to push back on those things.
I think we need
to modernize the institution.
If it's not working
for the American people,
if they don't feel like they kno
what we're what we do,
what we're accomplishing,
that we need to think
about how to change that.
And so
part of the reason
I've made use of those hearings
and use the white board in the h
is to try to show the American p
this is what I'm asking
and this is the answer that I'm
getting or not getting.
Sometimes in the case of a CEO
or a health administration offic
So if you go to the Senate,
the white board is coming with y
the white boards
definitely coming with me.
One of the great things about
the Senate is you serve on twice
as many committees.
You can take on more issues.
And then we have a lot
of special interests
and a lot of folks in power
who I think we need answers from
And so the Senate is a bigger op
to do that
and more opportunities
to work on the challenges
facing this country.
We should note
you were running against Adam Sc
and Barbara Lee for that nominat
Thank you so much for joining us
this morning.
The book is very interesting.
It's called I Swear My Life is m
than my life.
My minivan is messier than polit
Very good to have you on.
And thank you for that. Thank yo
We appreciate that.
Caitlin?
Congressman, they say if you wan
don't ask a busy mom, right?
I think, you know a little
she knows a little something abo
I'm looking forward to reading i
Congrats on the book.